human
beings are the only animals capable of
contemplating their own mortality and
they've been doing that for thousands of
years and yet somehow in the very recent
past we have lost the practical wisdom
of what happens as people
die I think that's a
problem and if you agree with me that it
is a problem then we have to work out
what we're going to do about
it when she was in her mid 20s in the
1920s my grandmother was already deeply
familiar with the sequence of events
that happened to a human person as they
were coming to the end of their life and
that's because as a woman and it was
usually women's work she was doing what
women had done done for centuries
looking after people at the very end of
their lives in their own beds in their
own homes supported by their own people
because hospital had nothing to offer
once a person was so sick that their
death was
imminent And yet when I reached my
mid-20s in the
1980s I had none of her wisdom and
understanding and knowledge of dying and
that was even though I'd just finished 5
years at medical school as a newly
qualified doctor I'd spent 5 years being
trained to stop people from
dying and actually if a death
happened it was a thing that was seen as
a medical disaster it was a thing that
was embarrassing it was a thing of which
we do not
speak why the difference and why within
just a couple of generations well think
about what happened to medicine over the
course of the 20th century it was not
worth going to hospital when you were
dying in the
1920s but by the 1960s 70s ' 80s and
onwards think of the Fantastic progress
that had been made so that people who
were so sick to that they might die of
course we took them to hospital because
there were antibiotics there were really
clever anesthetics that allowed surgeons
to spend a long time unpicking things
during operations there were new and
very sophisticated treatments for
cancers for heart failure for kidney
failure there were intensive care units
there was transplantation of organs some
of that pioneered In This Very City
Medical progress was astonishing taking
dying people to hospital very often
saved their lives and that is
fantastic and
yet and yet by taking dying people out
of home and putting them in hospital we
changed our understanding of the
process we lost our ownership of the
process and we gave it to
healthcare and we forgot what dying
looked
like so having been qualified for just
over four years I find myself in a new
job having originally intended a career
in cancer medicine
I've spent the last four years choosing
to train in the places where the most
sick people
were and then I realized that actually
what was really interesting to me was
the detective journey of symptom
management and the emotional integration
of feeling well enough to live a little
bit during the very end of life and I
went to work in a
hospice but I've been working in a big
teaching Hospital I'd learned a lot of
medicine I'd seen a lot lot of
dying we had a patient in the
hospice she was a memorable woman for
many reasons she had been a member of
the French Resistance during the second
world war she'd M married a British
Airman she'd come to live in England
she'd never lost her French
accent she had a cloud of Glorious white
hair like a Halo she had piercing Brown
eyes the kind of gaze that you feel a
person can see your
soul she was self-contained she was a
little bit aloof in fact she was a
little bit
scary one day she told the nurse who was
looking after her that she was terrified
of dying in agony because if she were to
die in agony she might despair in God
and if she were to despair in God as a
French Roman Catholic her belief was
that that would be a mortal sin so she
would not be able to go to heaven and
heaven was the place she knew her
husband was waiting for her this was a
profound existential
distress and my boss said well we need
to go and talk to her and you should
come you'll find this
interesting I was 26 do you remember 26
it's that kind of age the last age when
you know that you know
everything so I went along wondering
what I might learn cuz I thought I was
quite good at pain
control that
conversation changed my life it changed
my
career and it's brought me
here sitting on her bed with me on a
little foot stol so I can see him and
her and the nurse sitting on the chair
he said to her I'm concerned that you've
got worries about what might happen as
you're dying and she said yes she knew
him well she trusted him and he said I'm
sorry to hear that and I wondered
whether it might help you if I describe
to you what usually happens as a person
is
dying and I'm sitting on the stool of
all knowledge thinking well you can't
tell her
that because I've seen lots of dying and
I know they're all
different and she said yes please and he
said well I'll describe what we usually
see and if it gets too much you tell me
promise I'll
stop the thing that's really interesting
Sabine
is that as people are dying it doesn't
really matter what the illness is that
they're dying from the pattern of events
is very
similar we see people becoming more and
more tired it's harder and harder for
them to find the energy to do
things in fact they recharge their
energy not So Much by eating and
drinking but by
sleeping and as time goes by what we see
is that people sleep more and they're
awake less and if they want to do
something important they should take a
snooze before
it she nodded and she got hold of his
hand as time goes by he said we see
people are asleep for longer they're
awake for shorter and something
interesting we notice that they don't is
maybe it's medicine time or there's a
visitor we need to waken them for a
period we can't waken them they're not
just asleep they're actually
unconscious and when they waken they
tell us they've had a lovely sleep it
turns out that human beings don't
recognize when we become
unconscious and so at the very end of
somebody's life they're not just asleep
they're actually deeply unconscious and
when the brain is unconscious the only
part of it that's still working is the
part that's working their breathing by
now she is sitting right up in bed she's
got hold of one of his hands and she's
stroking it she's nodding at everything
he say says and in the meanwhile I'm
sitting on my stool horrified that he
seems to be describing dying to a dying
person and that feels to me to be really
not very
okay but she is
mesmerized by the time the brain is
deeply unconscious he's saying to her
now the only bit that's still working is
the bit that drives the breathing and so
breathing Cycles we don't normally see
start to happen reflex automatic
breathing Cycles from very deep breaths
becoming shallower and shallower and
then going back to the beginning again
cycles of fast breathing that gradually
become slower maybe with pauses and then
back to the beginning again the person
can't feel their throat they don't
notice if they breathe out through their
voice box making a noise families might
think that they're sighing or groaning
or uncomfortable will always check but
it's part of this reflex
breathing saliva or mouth cleaning fluid
won't irritate their throat it won't
make them cough or swallow they just lie
there with a little pool of fluid
sometimes in the back of their throat
it's not in the way air is moving in and
out of their lungs and it bubbles
through that little film of fluid but
families can mistake that for drowning
or choking so one of the things that
we'll do Sabine if your nieces and
nephews are here is we will make sure we
explain to them what is happening to
you she's stroking his hands she's
nodding she is absolutely taking in
everything that he
says and then he says and I think oh my
goodness he's going to the last
breath and then during usually one of
those phases of slow
breathing there'll be a breath
out that just isn't followed by another
breath in there is nothing special about
the last breath it's so not like on the
television or in cinema there's no rush
of pain at the end there's no sudden
Panic there's no feeling of fading away
sometimes we who work in paliative care
and I've subsequently delivered
discovered this to be true sometimes we
will walk into a room where a family has
been around a person who is in the act
of dying and we'll realize that person
has stopped breathing and the family
hasn't noticed yet because the Hollywood
finale that they're waiting for hasn't
happened she got hold of both of his
hands she shook them in hers and then
she pulled his hands to her face and she
kissed
them and then she closed her eyes eyes
she laid back on her pillows I just
watched her relax and in her own
inimitable and aloof way she told us
that we were no longer
required and my boss said to me are you
okay and I said
yes and I went to the kitchen to blow my
nose and dry my eyes and think about
what just
happened two huge ideas exploded fling
in my brain at the same time one
is how have I never noticed that that
pattern that he has just explained I
have seen hundreds of times but I was
the most Junior doctor it was my job to
stop the person dying remember so I was
so busy worrying about this person's
oxygen levels and that person's pulse
and this person's kidney function they
didn't stand back and see that there's a
pattern going on here
here we can describe the process of
ordinary human dying and it's as much a
process as the process of giving birth
is it has stages we can recognize them
we can Pace ourselves we can work out
where we are in
it but even more
fascinating was that realization from
watching sabine's
reaction that we can describe ordinary
dying to a dying
person and it shines the light of
understanding and information into that
dark place where all their fears and
Imagination were at
play I've gone on in my career in
paliative care to have that conversation
thousands of times countless times I
always offer to
stop I've never been
stopped but what happens at the end
is that relaxation that moment of well
that isn't what I was expecting followed
all almost immediately by can you tell
my family that can you tell my wife my
husband my kids my parents that's not
what we're expecting and I think we can
do
that so losing the wisdom really matters
and we can't leave it to paliative care
people or even medical people to to
reclaim that Lost Wisdom one family at a
time this is a massive social public
health
issue and I invite everybody who's
listening to step up the reason my
grandmother understood about dying was
that she'd seen it alongside people who
knew it who described to her as the
process was happening what she was
seeing so that she would understand and
not be
afraid and it requires all of us who are
Mortals all of us who love other Mortals
to step up to say enough death is not a
medical event it's a social event it's a
deeply personal
event and we can understand it we can
describe it we can console each
other we can accompany each other we can
reclaim
dying thank
[Music]
you